John joins us now and John please help
me out here because we're in Los Angeles
and we're kind of still in the I guess
the the morning stages of what happened
with the Dodgers and now we're thinking
could this possibly happen to the Astros
tonight against the Rays well Kirk good
morning good afternoon on the East Coast
it's a great question we saw two teams
both lose on home field
yesterday and and certainly there is
that pressure that comes with playing at
home and a decisive winner-take-all game
that's very real and I believe is the
factor for the Astros to reckon with
today they have not played well on the
offensive side of the baseball the last
three games they've scored seven runs in
the last three games in many ways
they're lucky that they're still alive
in this series because they nearly let
game to slip away and if that had
happened who knows maybe they would
already be getting ready for the off
season if that was the case for the
Houston Astros so they've got to find a
way to get the top of the lineup thrown
again Springer and Brantley I believe
are the two biggest names to watch
tonight from Houston to see if they get
to traffic on the bases for the big bat
in the middle part of the lineup but the
Astros have their ace whether you want
to call them 1a 1a 1b depending how you
look at Cole and Verlander they've got
the right guy on the mound they're also
facing someone and Tyler glass now who I
thought was very good in the first game
of this series and and now they got to
deal with them once again so it should
be too dynamic right arms you're going
to see power stuff on the fs1 broadcast
tonight beginning at 7 o'clock Eastern I
can't wait to see how it all plays out
it's going to be a desperate game on
both sides with you certainly Houston
having a lot more to lose they're the
team that's expected to win they've got
the most Wednesday's ball this year
they're supposed to win this baseball
game but as we saw yesterday what is
supposed to happen is not always what
does happen MLB Network and Fox Sports
MLB analyst John Morosi joining the Rich
Eisen show Kirk Morrison here filling in
for rich so you mentioned it as Cole
versus glass now but when you look at
right now in a game five scenario you
mentioned Verlander as well but when you
look at both of these
I guess relief pitching right now the
relievers in this game what do you think
has the edge if one of these starters
gets touched up early on everybody
because that is their DNA that is how
they have run games all season long I
think however long however long we see
glass now go
what is diego castillo or nick anderson
who got into a game very early in in
Game four the earliest he has ever been
involved in a game was that game for
they've got Emilio pecan colin po che we
could see Blake's now come out of the
bullpen we could even see Charlie Morton
the former Astro that the Sion
candidates with the Rays pitching in
relief today they have the much better
setup once the starter leaves the game
then Houston does right now Houston it
has had some struggling bullpen issues
here of late when you think about Ryan
Presley still coming back from a knee
issue Roberto Osuna I had to be rescued
there in the second game of this series
so if the game is tied or even if the
Ray is if it's a seventh inning and Cole
was out of the game and the Rays are
down a run they don't like their chances
or whatever the wind probability says
Tampa Bay is going to like their chances
to win the ballgame if they're within a
run or if they are tied or ahead
certainly in the seventh inning or later
if caracoles out of the baseball game
John Merrow see MLB Network and Fox
Sports MLB analysts joining the Rich
Eisen show but you know John I know we
have game five tonight in the ALDS but
when you look at last night's NLDS the
two games between obviously the
Cardinals and the Braves and know
obviously the Dodgers going against the
Nationals and I'll start with the
Cardinals and Braves just a little bit
just kind of what happened how it
unraveled so fast and were you expecting
more from this Braves team that just
didn't really show up yesterday I was
expecting more I think Mike foltynewicz
maybe just got a little too amped up in
that situation sometimes when when that
happens you just don't have the command
that you usually do and I think that was
part of the issue yesterday obviously a
very fluky
and that from that standpoint to played
a role early in that ball game as well
so it was a combination of factors from
Atlanta side of things and obviously
good good hitting good timing on the
part of the Cardinals a ten run first
inning is not something that we ever
expect to see and no matter how erratic
a pitcher is and I think that was a an
aberration of aberration the only time
ever we've seen it in the postseason
history having that happened in the
first inning so it was a very surprising
result but at the end of the day Kirk I
would tell you that from my perspective
the Braves lost this series in Game one
Wow with with the base running mistakes
by Ronald Acuna jr. not running a ball
out ball off the wall he only got the
first base on it and and as Brian McCann
said after the game 90 feet the playoff
game is a big deal and and that was a
significant problem for the Braves in
that game and and unfortunately for a
cunha as sterling seasoned he's one of
the great stars of the game you can have
a great career but when there is a fault
of a lack of effort in a stage that big
that costs your team and your the
franchise player that is a very very
difficult burden to bear from now until
whatever the Braves can advance in the
playoffs that that's that's gonna be
part of his is his biography until he
can find a way to erase it and win so
that's a and and numerous players Brian
McCann Artie Freeman Ozzie alby's after
that game criticized their teammate on
the record and said that shouldn't
happen so clearly there's a level of
frustration there with a player who has
the potential of the ability to change
the game it was a bad look in Game one
and as much as people might want to say
well the Braves what an embarrassing way
to lose Game five with that 10 run first
inning I think in many ways the more the
more difficult moment for them to have
to reckon with is what happened in Game
one yeah you mentioned it a younger
player and lacunae junior having to kind
of go through the growing pains of a
major league baseball and understanding
that the playoffs are a little bit
different and he's gonna live with that
one for a while maybe he can change kind
of the perception of what happened in
this NLDS but I'll shift to the other
game and we're talking about a
who was been in this league for a long
time and has pitched many great games
but when it comes to the playoffs it's
been Clayton Kershaw's kryptonite and
last night we saw it again giving up the
back-to-back home runs after you know
basically you know getting out of the
seventh inning but when you watched last
night's game though John what did you
see from the Dodgers that they could
have done differently and I hate to say
that but who's more at fault here is it
Kershaw the way he pitched or is it his
manager Dave Roberts for leaving them in
there there's a lot of blame right now
Kirk had to go around with the Dodgers
I think it's shared among multiple
parties here I do not believe Dave
Roberts put Kershaw in a situation to
succeed but also from Clayton standpoint
giving up home runs on consecutive
pitches would to me indicate that that
there was a flaw on the game plan and
and from his perspective I think Sean
Casey made a very good point on every
network last night the pitch to Rend own
is forgivable that was down and one of
the best hitters in the game got it out
of the ballpark
that I don't have a big issue with with
Kershaw not giving up that home run it
did not tie the game at that point in
time it was to a righty
the pitch was relatively well located I
can live with that one but that the the
cutter up that so delayed out that has
to be located better that was that was
right in the hitting zone the very next
pitch it was up it was over the plate
and and Ford it for Dave Roberts you put
Kershaw in there to get Soto out you
have got to get that hitter out that is
the guy that Kershaw was still in the
game to get because if he wasn't going
to have success against Soto then
Roberts should put in my to deal with
Rendon and then live with the
possibility of Soto do damage against my
edit but that was the guy that Kershaw
had to get out obviously it didn't
happen Kershaw I thought was very
accountable after the game and speaking
about the criticism that he's getting
right now and he said everything that's
being said I deserve it he took the loss
on his own shoulders there was never an
issue of accountability with Clinton
Kershaw
but the reality is
the Dodgers were somewhat disorganized
in their bullpen late in the season
Kenley Jansen
Dave Roberts said late in the year
supposedly was there closer in the
division series but he pitched twice
once with the team up by six and once
when they were down by four that does
not sound like the way that you used a
closer and and so there was a disconnect
between internal/external what was going
on there
how do you now handle Joe Kelly how do
you handle Kelly Jensen in the offseason
oh by the way probably your most
consistent start or at least the first
half was dungeon Ryu he's a free agent
now rich L is a free agent now how
confident are you with a Bueller led
staff that also includes Kershaw maybe
fading a bit my Aida and then some youth
already asked for counseling is that
your starting five for next year do you
have to bring back Ryu there's a lot of
questions right now for the Dodgers it'd
be a lot easier for them to take if they
had won a couple years ago when they had
probably a better chance to do it again
the Astros and Kershaw at Game five of
that series get away so I think we
sometimes look at the last result and
and and really judge a lot on I think in
this case there is something to be
judged from it but also the larger
picture here I believe Kirk the Dodgers
at different times were very cautious at
the trade deadline they did not get
Justin Verlander what I probably should
have this year at the deadline they did
not make a big move for a reliever and I
think the the passive nature of their
deadlines Kirk has now come back to
haunt the Los Angeles Dodgers oh man
just a couple more minutes here with MLB
Network and Fox Sports MLB analyst John
Merrow see John so are you saying that
the Dodgers dynasty or their little run
is probably on its downswing or could it
possibly still be on an upward
trajectory it that's a great question
Kirk I I think that they still had the
players to be a a sustainable winning
ballclub they've got when you think
about the Will Smith coming up this year
Gavin what's coming up this year I
mentioned Gosselin who tree house is
still relatively young pitcher they've
had a lot of contributions Matt Bailey
is one more name garlic added big
contribution this year as well as
different times the number of players
debuting on this team for a team of this
caliber was extraordinary for the
Dodgers this year
however when you see what's happened now
in the plas you see how competitive now
the National League is and the Nationals
will be back next year they'll be good I
expect other teams to take a step
forward the the separation between the
Dodgers and everybody else is mer aware
now that it's then it's been in a while
we saw that happen in this series and I
really think Kirk that so much of
baseball now is as a matter of syncing
up your biggest moves with your best
windows to win the Astros we're speaking
here at Houston they did that two years
ago with the Verlander trade obviously
it was unique circumstances in August
they were able to make the trade happen
but so much of baseball the Royals in
2015 they made a big move to Johnny
Cueto and Ben Zobrist and they gave up
some prospects and and they're going to
rebuild out but hey they always say the
flag flies forever Dodgers still need a
flag to fly ok they we can't call them a
dynasty without a championship and I
think that in some in some ways Kirk the
core of that team it's best chances to
win may well have now pass them by and
we're about to see do the Dodgers react
emotionally and sign a Gerrit Cole for
example or an Anthony Rendon and move
some pieces around the diamond how
aggressive are they going to be will
they maintain their current course of
caution and sustainable winning but
obviously so far not winning the
ultimate prize hey John last question
before I let you go right now currently
eight teams will be looking for new
managers next year in baseball gabe
kapler just being let go by the
Philadelphia Phillies could the Dodgers
also be in that situation or how do you
think first of all the Phillies feel
their role but then out here in
California Joe Maddon is kind of walking
around here and definitely probably a
hot commodity right now this offseason
he is a very hot commodity Kirk I think
Joe Maddon will be the next manager of
the Angels I do that they slopes more
interviews to go reportedly this week
John Farrell Buck Showalter interesting
that that now it seems very invoked for
teams that are trying to win they now
want experienced managers again for a
while that are moving away from that
younger managers Arron Boone Alex Cora
not yet managed league level Andy green
who was fired in San Diego Gabe Kapler
in Philadelphia so I think now we're
seeing experience matter a little bit
more and and that to me is going to be
the flavor of this offseason [ __ ] shell
Walters got a good chance to get a job
Joe Girardi I would be stunned stunned
Kirk if Joe Girardi is not managing
somebody probably to the Mets for the
Phillies or the Cubs in the next couple
weeks I think he's that strong of a
candidate Dave Roberts is safe my
judgment I can't imagine there's any any
threat to his job right now
the Dodgers have a very collaborative
approach to their to their in-game
decision making and I think that that
was part of the game plan yesterday
Dave Roberts has won the most games in
baseball's and since he took over I
can't imagine any change happening there
but III do expect again Joe Maddon
probably will get a job there with the
Angels I think a very high probability
there and then now the East Coast the
Phillies I believe much like the Met I
would expect to hire someone with
experience that's a key part of what's
needed right now in the game of the
Phillies will go in that direction with
both Buck Showalter and potentially how
about this Dusty Baker yeah he managed
Bryce Harper in DC one of the great
classy people we've seen in the game for
the entirety of his career personally
I've wanted to see dust to get one more
chance at this and I think the Phillies
he's always managed star Laden teams
very well Kirk because of his
personality you relate so all to
everybody I think Dusty Baker and
Philadelphia would be a fantastic fit
well you keep using the word experience
and that's why we go to you for our MLB
news John because you have nothing but
experience hey I appreciate Kirk I
always enjoy our conversations going
back years ago you've been a great
friend always being on the show what
they do a fantastic job host an analyst
everything to do Kirk so it's great to
talk with you today thanks I learned
from you John such a such a great
tonight thanks John that's John Rossi
MLB Network and Fox Sports MLB analysts
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the
rich eyes and show app